[Musik]
ja
stimmt was sind Titel steht
[Musik]
ich bin ab morgen um 38 zum Sport
gefahren kam dann irgendwann so gegen 10
Uhr wieder und habe gesehen dass meine
Tür offen stand bin dementsprechend
direkt meine Wohnung eingelaufen und so
ein bisschen geguckt was Phase ist habe
so hallo gefragt wegen der vielleicht da
war ein paar Freunde von mir am zweiten
Schlüssel und er musste dann feststellen
dass meine ganze Wohnung leer war
seit ca so aus die haben sogar den Boden
geklaut zum Glück habe ich an und um
meine Wohnung herum alles Video
überwacht so dass ich dann direkt in
meine App reingegangen bin und zu
schauen ob bei mir eingebrochen wurde
und siehe da
[Musik]
stimmt
hier seht ihr die Überwachungskamera
Aufnahmen
[Musik]
doch ich habe mir geschworen dass dieser
elendige Einbrecher
nicht ungeschoren davonkommen
an ihm rächen
rächen wie Gartengeräte
ja wir spielen tatsächlich den Simulator
heute damit ich mich ein bisschen auf
meinen ersten Einbruch vorbereite weil
ich will jetzt so eine kriminelle
Karriere anstreben
ist
[Musik]
Brecheisen aufheben und das Brecheisen
verwenden um den Sound zu brechen alles
klar Willi
[Musik]
wo bin ich denn hier schon wieder wir
konzentrieren uns allerdings gar nicht
auf meine begeben
aus diesem Grund geht alles glatt wie
Glatteis ich soll also in das Haus da
hinten einbrechen von daher
[Musik]
ist das Feuer
die neue Rolex vielleicht ist das ja wie
in Minecraft und wir können das Feuer
ein bisschen abbauen
das vibriert ihr denn schon wieder
meine Schwester im Haus ne ja guck mal
hier hat man auf dem Vorgarten gehabt
hast
[Musik]
warum wurde ich denn jetzt zurückgesetzt
und wer sagt dann die
da steht einer am Fenster
hey
oh
vielleicht sollten wir unsere Diebes
Karriere noch mal ein bisschen
[Musik]
die bleibt dabei also wir müssen hier
anscheinend ein bisschen nebenan her und
ducken
[Musik]
werden hier haben wir keinen drin glaube
ich
[Musik]
nicht hier guck mal
aus diesem Fenster rausschaut
ich habe eine Mission ich habe eine
Missionen
ich habe eine Mission
en
oder was
müssen
ach du scheiße
ich müsste man da lang
es war
wenn ich
ich gebe dir auch 5 € dafür
bei Mission Impossible hier schön bei
der Birgit lang und jetzt ganz schnell
bei dem Lothar um die Ecke rum so dass
der uns nicht sieht und jetzt geht's
schnell weiter
ich bin hier
nein das habe ich nicht zugehört was ich
machen muss okay wir sollen das Window
aufbrechen also das Fenster zunächst
einmal brauchen wir die Taschenlampe
ohne Halt in die Luft in sein blödes
Gesicht
ja gut
jetzt brauchen wir die Taschen einfach
schon hell im Hellen bricht sich viel
einfacher ein weil man keine
Taschenlampe braucht hier vorne rein
müssen hier vorne ist unser Fluchtweg
denke ich mal das wichtigste ne wenn ihr
eine kriminelle Karriere anstreben wollt
als allererstes ans Ende denken
nein
wir sollen das Fenster aufbrechen
ich wollte gerade ausholen und es geht
schon kaputt
und klettern hier rein so wir können
jetzt
danke danke
ich brauche diese Taschenlampe nicht
wieso ist die schon dabei
[Musik]
oh ich habe mir in die Hosen geschmissen
hier vorne wird unser Fluchtweg sein
denke ich mal von daher schiebe ich das
hier direkt mal schon auf und jetzt
können wir hier nämlich auch scannen was
sie die ganzen Sachen kosten guck mal
der Toaster ist wertvoll den nehmen wir
uns als allererstes und Pack nehmen wenn
wir den hier über die Schulter legen da
hinten in den Rucksack rein das Ding
kostet gar nichts von der Räume mal ein
bisschen auf kannst weg
was bin ich für ein G dass ich das Ding
da so hingeworfen habe im Kühlschrank
wenn Sie wahrscheinlich keine Wert
Gegenstände haben hier vorne auch nicht
denke ich äh hier vorne das ist alles
wertlos das hier ist wertlos und wertlos
kommen ein bisschen auf hier
das erkläre
das war hier eine kleine
aber gut ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt
mal
was ist denn jetzt hier
wo bin ich denn jetzt schon wieder ich
würde sagen wir gehen jetzt mal hier
vorne in das Nebenzimmer rein und
schauen uns hier noch mal kurz um hier
können wir uns
verstecken steht hier also wenn wir hier
sind können wir uns unter das
schauen wir uns mal hier die Preise an
wir haben ja ach guck mal mashallah an
weißes Hemd ein rotes T-Shirt er mir
noch die Schuhe dicker geil ich stehe
auf Schuhe hier vorne haben wir noch
eine Cap die kostet wie teuer sind Cap
10 $ nehmen wir auch noch mit schau mal
an haben wir hier vorne noch paar Sachen
drin was ist denn hier vielleicht
Badezimmer ja guck mal das Badezimmer
auch drin was haben wir hier das hier
kostet gar nichts Klopapier ist auch
wertlos können wir
ne
doch hier vorne können wir auch
rausgehen glaube ich einfach hier raus
würde ich sagen machen wir das Fenster
hoch und klettern hier durch sind jetzt
hier am Rand aber andere Räume gibt es
glaube ich eh nicht an doch guck mal
hier vorne gab es noch Raum aber ich
glaube da kann man
nee das hätte ich auch schon gedacht
weil das sind einfach auf der anderen
Seite wieder rausgehen können die muss
natürlich verschlossen sein das ist ja
die Eingangstür hier vorne die Cola Dose
kostet dementsprechend auch nichts den
Stuhl mitnehmen
[Applaus]
hallo aber gut okay wir müssen
anscheinend jetzt hier lang weil da
vorne ist das nächste Ding und dann
machen wir uns natürlich auf
[Musik]
wie komme ich denn hier raus
oh
die Tür war okay die Tür war offen von
daher gehen wir jetzt mal zu unserem
Auto da muss da vorne um die Ecke steht
wenn da jetzt eine Schrottkarre steht ne
ich war euch dann habe ich gar keinen
Bock auf dieses Spiel ein Einbrecher ich
sag's euch so ein richtig
haben immer so krank steht Lamborghini
verraten Porsche mit irgendwie sowas und
wir haben eine
Taxi
also wir haben ja echt bei der
Inneneinrichtung komplett gespart aber
gut greife mal das Ding hier
setzen uns hin und los geht's
[Musik]
ich fahre echt sehr gut oh
habe ich Notfall gebaut
[Musik]
Spiel gespeichert komm rein was das hier
unser Lager oder was
ich brauche keinen Schlaf
aber gut meine Damen und Herren das hier
ist anscheinend unser Lager wo wir dann
unsere ganzen Sachen die wir so geklaut
haben lagern hier vorne haben wir ein
Radio können wir wahrscheinlich noch
anmachen wir haben hier vorne unseren
Tresor wir haben äh dahinten einen
kleinen Küchenbereich und unsere kleine
bartnische und da oben können wir uns
schlafen legen das werden wir jetzt auch
mal direkt machen denn wir müssen ja fit
sein für unsere nächsten Einbruch der
vielleicht bald kommen wird wenn ihr das
also sehen wollt dann lasst einen Daumen
hoch unter dem Video da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocken und ich
gehe jetzt schlafen
Nacht ist
schlafen bis 11 Uhr
wir sehen uns ciao